[Music]
foreign
at the wildlife SOS animal rescue
sanctuary in Agra Northern India hello
Kohl's come in from a concerned member
of the public
outside the house where are you calling
from
a monkey's been reported paralyzed on a
sidewalk in the city's bustling downtown
district
Wildlife sos's beiju Raj and volunteer
vet Dr Paul Ramos are sent to
investigate
this is a monkey injured call
so we have to go and find out whether
the monkey is really sick or what
happened
the animals located 11 miles east of the
sanctuary
[Music]
how many monkeys are here the city it is
estimated for twenty thousand twenty
thousand in Negra City yeah what kind of
monkey do you think this is going to be
this is macaque we have to be very
careful sometimes they can be very
aggressive and dangerous and ferocious
the situation here with monkeys is a
contradiction
with the religion they're seen as sacred
and they're given respect and on
Tuesdays and Saturdays they feed them
but for the rest of the week they're
terrorizing people
it is a major major issue monkeys are
becoming Menace
we had made them pissed
feeding them and I don't consider it
their fault it's not his fault it's
coming for food and shelter
the biggest reason really why monkeys
are living in the cities is that we are
crashing into their homes we're mowing
down their forests and they have nowhere
to go
to bed excuse me
watch out cow pardon me
Mr Cow
[Music]
we are here
we have to go on foot now
um we gotta walk because you just can't
make it with a car so we're bringing all
that we need
[Music]
you got to watch the road for the cars
and your head for the wires
they're everywhere
dealing with a troop of monkeys can be
terrifying basically you're dealing with
yes one potentially dangerous animal
right in front of you but then all of
his buddies surround you like a street
gang in a coordinated fashion they can
attack and they can do a lot of damage
the lanes are getting
narrower and narrower
all above us are monkeys now the monkeys
yeah
here's the monkey we got the monkey here
he's down
he's holding his leg really funny like I
think this is his left hind leg not able
to move properly but he's really really
still alert our plan which should be one
person should be covering that area and
I'll be just go and grab him
we may have to be very careful with
other monkeys as well they may sometimes
playing on us so please be careful
one concern is that these type of
monkeys the macaques carry something
called herpes B for us it can be fatal
so we don't want to get their saliva we
don't get bitten peed or put on there's
a lot of things that we have to be
concerned about
his buddies here
we don't know what he's gonna do and we
don't know what his friends are gonna do
we have to be really careful right now
are you ready
all right
friends are starting to chatter
we're gonna put him in here this is the
danger point this is danger point
he's a big monkey
very fast very strong
watch out
now everybody's looking at us Yep
they're all looking at us
whilst the monkey refuses to enter the
cage The Troop surrounds the team
we should get out of here
nowhere in someone's house the monkeys
are right outside
they were gathering around and they were
starting they were about ready to uh
they were gonna they're ready to pounce
on us they were getting ready to attack
fortunately this family they kind of
saved us because it was going down
I must say I've never been in this type
of situation before we are going to trap
in this small room yeah the whole day
this is crazy I mean it's like the
Planet of the Apes out there baju you
know I can tell looking at his face he's
trying to trying to look calm but in the
inside he's a bit rattled
he's like the Zen master of animal
rescue so if he starts to get a little
bit concerned you know I need to be
really really concerned
for now we're trapped
[Music]
at the wildlife SOS animal rescue
sanctuary in Agra Northern India my life
SMS how can I help you could you hold on
just a minute another animal rescue call
has come in we've received Intel about
one elephant that really needs our help
huh in a legally owned elephant is
reportedly being used to beg for money
on a city streets
there are about 3 500 elephants in
captivity in India and people are
exploiting them for money in temples on
the streets using them for begging and
for tourists ride
babies are captured from the wild taken
away from their families these are wild
animals we are talking about
captive elephants in India are kept
under extremely depraved conditions they
don't get adequate Veterinary Care
almost all of them are underweight
they'll be covered in sores from just
laying in concrete these elephants also
tend to be very fearful
[Music]
the training process is designed to
cause psychological damage
to break the spirit of that animal
these injuries will take years to be
fixed if ever
Wildlife sos's mission is to rescue
these animals and provide them with a
better life if they're 145 acre elephant
sanctuary
my goal would be to liberate all captive
elephants
but we can only liberate One Elephant at
a time
I'm gonna go rescue that elephant bring
it back to our Hospital give her some
help and make sure she never has to face
begging on the street again
we've already sent out an advanced team
to exactly pinpoint the location of the
elephant
[Music]
38 miles east of the elephant Sanctuary
is the densely populated city of
ferozabad
inside this Urban Jungle the elephant
was recently spotted being exploited for
begging
[Music]
volunteer vet Dr Izzy herji is joining
Wildlife sos's undercover mission to
help rescue the elephant from a lifetime
of captivity
we're about seven kilometers away from
where the elephant is supposed to be in
a Marketplace of sorts and so we're
dressed up in civilian clothes and gonna
try and blend in just as tourists
browsing around
got this little GoPro with me and
hopefully we can get some discreet shots
kind of check out the elephant's Health
a little bit
we don't really know exactly what we're
getting into it could turn into a
situation with uh large crowds and MOB
mentality
everyone wants to ensure that we don't
compromise this elephant's safety or our
own
let's start walking in
those kids just said the elephant is in
this direction
there she is
surrounded by quite the crowd so gotta
be a little careful here
the elephant is seeing kept with some
people who are posing as holy men to
provide blessings to people in exchange
for offerings or money
[Music]
wielding those objects like their Spears
or holy objects but they're actually
bull hooks in Disguise so we know how
they're controlling this elephant
seems to be moving her
right leg with some stiffness probably
from putting lots of weight on it over
time
it's hard to imagine what this elephant
must have been through
paraded around these streets
and people yelling and riding her and
we're gonna come back for her we're
gonna do this
Wildlife SOS it's attempting to rescue
an illegally owned captive elephant
back at the sanctuary Carter has just
received vital intelligence from his
vets on the ground
[Music]
our team have just reported
elephants in a bad way
we need to leave right now
when we find an elephant that needs
rescuing we work with the forest
department and the police to get
permission to move that elephant
we now have that permission
[Applause]
[Music]
sometimes we've had situations where
we've had mobs trying to burn our
ambulance down beat up our staff we've
had to call police to intervene and help
us so yes
um I am on edge when I'm on these risk
operations
they're outside the door now waiting for
us you can see them
the wildlife SOS rapid response team is
in the busy back Lanes of Agra Northern
India
it's been called to rescue one of the
city's twenty thousand monkeys
monkeys are getting attacked by dogs
attacked by people
electrified by all the wires hit by cars
basically they're living in an urban
environment where everything is out to
get them
having successfully netted the injured
macaque
they're now hiding from the monkey's
true
it is difficult dealing with a troop of
monkeys they are very social animals
they want to protect their entire troop
and if somebody is in danger they all
will try to attack you
they can bite and take a chunk out of
your body
watch your fingers watch your fingers
okay now we can press this end there you
go got him now the question is can we
escape
yeah
I'm worried that we underestimated these
guys we weren't fast enough getting that
monkey in the box and now we're going to
pay the price
[Music]
how's it looking out there about you
they are all still there just on the
window
there's one right there
they want their friend back
would it be better to either wait longer
or create a diversion no no we don't
want that because it is going to gather
more monkeys so it is better to leave
now yeah yeah we have to move
leaving we should be quickly running
from this location we cannot just walk
don't look uh above don't give eye
contact with the monkeys when we get out
that door we're gonna have to go go go
They're gonna be right on us can you
carry the monkey you get the weapons I
get the monkey
I can protect you from behind and hatham
can protect you from friend yeah okay
you ready yes all right
[Music]
oh the monkeys are back they're they're
following us from behind enough above
so we gotta move fast
I'm gonna feel a lot better when we're
back in the car because I can still hear
him behind us
poor guy
you know captured up can't walk
in a box and carried down there I'll
throw it away from his family and
friends he must be really scared
that was crazy oh my God it was little
too much crazy yeah yeah that was close
at least since my cat said really
dangerous they can kill a human being
they literally can kill human beings
in this place you never know what to
expect
and I definitely wasn't expecting that
it feels like we're at the front lines
of where that's all happening I mean
that was just crazy
I know a thing or two about being
attacked by monkeys now
very very dominant nature
that's one way of putting it yeah yeah
it's they just dominate the people
because they get food yeah I mean so so
literally in the monkey's mind yeah they
are dominant to us because we're giving
them food so we make it much worse for
ourselves when we feed them
feeding the Beast
the team needs to find out why the
macaque's hind legs are paralyzed
it's a big monkey dude
getting angry
beiju and Paul passed the injured
macaque over to senior Veterinary
surgeon Dr Ilya Raja salvaraj
giving support to the wildlife is my
passion
it's not just a job it is our mission
it was a very hard rescue he was not
going to the cage he was holding yeah
he'll put up a fight oh my God we can
give mild suggestion we can check it
thoroughly yeah we need to give him a
little bit of a jab to make him fall
asleep so we can safely examine him and
treat any wounds he might he might have
hey look at me
hey I think it's not feeling right yeah
did he not feel it at all that's not a
good sign yeah yeah didn't even flinch
he's going down well now yeah
now it's gonna be our first real look at
him yeah
big wound there left timed this this
abrasion's right hand we're doing quick
radiography examination all right we
should move out clear up
an x-ray will pinpoint the monkey's
injury
the team suspects a damaged spinal cord
or multiple broken bones could be
causing the paralysis
oh
I see something what is it
it looks to me like a pellet
at India's Wildlife SOS Animal Rescue
Center
the right show there I'm going to zoom
in here
team is discovered the partially
paralyzed macaque monkey has been shot
that looks like a pellet
yeah
when I saw the bullet I was shocked
I wasn't expecting to see that
another one
there's that one which is up near the
chest
and then there's a lower one here which
is why we're not moving our leg so it's
only two right yes the good news is
we're not completely paralyzed we don't
have a broken back this might be fixable
I can feel on this so you can feel it
yeah oh wow
I mean the good thing about this wound
is you can you can see it you can feel
it therefore you can cut it out
so now we'll make a small injection and
I will try to take the bullet off from
the area well the pellets right in in
the joint of his arm so every little
movement he's making is an agonizing
pain and his feeding is jumping his
movement everything will be an issue
we've got to get this pellet out
sometimes the longer it's in the body
kind of forms a capsule or scar tissue
around it yeah
yeah oh it's coming out do you got it
there it is
there we go
there is no word for me I'm like shocked
this macaque is an example I guess of
why I came here
's an animal who through no fault of his
own has been drawn into
this you know unfortunate interaction
with people and people have created this
situation and I guess I feel
passionately that I need to be a part of
the solution to that
will we be taking out the other pellet
as well today no the other one is a bit
deep enough okay so that one's too deep
for today yeah yeah yeah
we have a good bedding for him to wake
up very nicely
is this reversal yeah yes wakey wakey
he's just really you know an innocent
victim in it all I'm really glad that we
were there to hopefully help them yes we
hope for the best there he comes look at
that he's looking around
[Music]
even after an operation to remove the
second pellet the team suspects he'll
never have enough Mobility to be
released
instead he'll be moved to the sanctuary
to recuperate where he can settle in
with his new monkey family
that's the man who fixed you
that was a good day's work we got to
rescue him figure out what's wrong and
put him on his path to treatment
that's a good day
[Music]
30 miles east Wildlife SOS founder
cardick is leading the elephant rescue
Convoy
following the undercover operation the
team now knows its exact location
isolated from their own kind begging
elephants live unnatural lives
getting her safe and in the company of
other elephants is crucial to her
well-being
Izzy is going to join us they're going
to pick him up if he can get the
elephant right away we will we'll do
whatever it takes to get this elephant
back home nothing will stop us let's go
make this happen let's do it
the photos department has received a
tip-off that the elephant has been
spotted in a field just outside of
ferozabad
we are literally four or five minutes
away from where then if it is now
because it's really large it's going to
attract a lot of attention so I feel the
best thing for us to do is you know
weepy laugh leave the Convoy behind
let's just go to a little investigation
on our own make sure the elephant is
there what the situation is yeah sounds
perfect to me
[Music]
thank you
there she is
[Music]
not get too close and right now she's
very conscious of our presence
[Music]
she looks extremely agitated back and
forth
and you can see there's a rope on the
leg there
that's actually a spiked bracelet
it's called a punching and it's a spiked
bracelet it's got spikes on the inside
it's probably poking her wow and and
giving her a lot of pain
she's not a happy girl this morning this
open mouth kind of behavior which tells
me that she's in a lot of stress right
now
how old do you think she is I would
think
she's probably between 40 and 50.
yeah she's she's had a bad deal look at
that oh my God she has no
joint ability on that yeah she cannot
can't Flex that wrist oh my goodness
and this well is right here yes it's
easily possible for her to fall into it
and maybe break a leg or something yeah
listen we've now got the elephant bring
the Convoy right away thank you okay bye
she's in pretty rough shape
it's gonna be okay
this is our team the Convoy has come
ambulance is right here
wow finally get some food
oh there's a jackpot
hopefully we've won her heart with all
the food that we gave her
the forest department is already here
finishing off the paperwork and will
then hand over the elephant to us
legally if we get it into the ambulance
I think you know we can be home safe
yeah
but moving a two and a half ton animal
that doesn't know you and trusts you is
risky we are now opening up the rope in
the front
she could just turn around and charge us
and she could be out of control
kick
oh don't kick don't kick don't kick
as part of a nationwide Crackdown
Wildlife SOS is working with the forest
Department to rescue an illegally owned
begging elephant
we have to keep watching her constantly
she's not gonna
turn around and back us
[Music]
malnourished and in pain
the team needs to get her off the
streets and back to the safety of its
sanctuary
foreign
hopefully she's okay with us walking
with her and doesn't freak out
excellent
you can do it you're sweet let me come
in front with the bananas I think so
don't worry
very good very good
okay I'm gonna throw a banana yeah yeah
please go ahead okay there you go
she's searching for the banana
wow
look at that she's in she's in
I don't know when the last time she saw
fresh hay and sugar cane was
I cannot tell you how much this this
means to me we've been able to bring her
to safety an incredible way to help such
an elephant and she deserves every bit
of help we can give her
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
after a long slow drive through the
night
the rescued elephant arrives at the
sanctuary
[Music]
so there's axes and all kinds of hooks
and stuff so let's start getting all
that off
I think every single day of her life
she's been beaten with an ax
cars all over her forehead her forehead
is dotted with scars all over you can
see all the wounds and the scars around
yeah just look at that ah my goodness
[Music]
never have pain from these things again
having spent years abused and alone this
elephant also carries psychological
scars
family groups where socialization and
communication are really important to
their daily life whereas a captive
elephant lives in total isolation
they're deprived of contact with other
elephants these elephants have really
serious psychological conditions that
are linked to captivity
in the hopes that introducing her to
other elephants will heal some of those
scars
but first she should be initiated into
the wildlife SOS family
what we're going to be doing is a
welcoming ceremony and the naming
ceremony when a new elephant is risked
we always welcome her with prayers
asking for God's blessings to support
her and have a safe secure and a
pain-free future
we pray to Lord Ganesh who's the
elephant god
[Music]
Sandy is going to seek the blessings of
Lord Ganesh beautiful
and there you go good girl
the Bell off okay
yeah almost free
that's it there we go her Bell's off
wishing you a better life
from that moment onwards she's taken
care of and we are going to be calling
her kalpana
[Music]
the name that's been chosen is kalpana
which means imagination or dreams you
know Karthik this was the most special
moment of the whole rescue
now she's someone and not something
anymore she's kalpana
that is the key to the beginning of her
new life it's shedding everything in the
past behind and starting fresh just a
little bit of love and you can change an
animal's life forever
it's time for kalpana to get a long
overdue health check by Dr yaduraj card
picker
since I was a kid I always loved always
love animals and then I started working
with Wildlife SOS
so my love for wildlife just got bigger
she's got some really horrendous
long-standing injuries the biggest
concern for us was that huge swollen
right wrist
we have this portable x-ray unit to take
a look at what kind of injuries she
might have sustained
this unit we're using right now is
actually an equine x-ray unit so we
don't have x-ray machines specially
designed for Elephants yet
which should work just fine
ready shot
loading okay great
that's totally abnormal that's not
looking like normal joint at all this is
really bad this is really bad
[Music]
oh
safe in the hands of wildlife SOS
kalpana's swollen right wrist is x-rayed
it's an ugly joint ugly and must be
painful
none of that is normal she has complete
Fusion of her joint you can't see any
details of joint structure these are
calcified bone spurs that her body has
thrown up in an effort to stabilize an
injured joint and they're just growing
outwards
uh problems is reversible sadly uh
uh yeah yeah yeah just just an ugly join
foreign so she had some sort of fracture
of one of her carpal bones at some point
but obviously she wasn't allowed to rest
and basically her body just had to put
down a gigantic watermelon of a callus
in order to finally stabilize that joint
by fusing the whole thing shut
ready click
the doctors prescribe anti-inflammatory
medicine for calpinos painful swollen
wrist
[Music]
oh
it's kind of hard to explain the extent
of the pain that she's been going under
and the extent of the neglect
so it's heartbreaking but it's also
she's inspiring because she inspires us
all to
to make it stop
[Music]
[Applause]
another animal emergency call has come
in hello world how can I help
there's a cobra in your school
Wildlife SOS scrambles a rapid response
team 15 miles east to the farming region
of karmana
I came to India because this is the
place to learn about wildlife and people
and their interactions it's never been
as important as it is right now to
understand the natural world and to
protect it
what are we off to it's in school and a
cobra is inside so the whole school is
panic it is a big worry
lots of snake bites
bite are on the increase there are 1.3
billion people here so natural habitat
for snakes is shrinking at Wildlife as
well 30 to 40 snake calls every day and
the number is increasing
so baju yes I don't want to act paranoid
or anything but it seems like every time
you get a snake call
someone puts me on it
maybe because you like snakes
I love snakes
I love snakes because I had grown up
with them and
I love them because they don't love us
there are almost 300 Snake species in
India 60 of them are venomous and four
of them are super lethal and this is one
of the four
so she's the lady what found a snake
they're really relying on us to locate
the snake there's lots of kids around
this is a dangerous situation for kids
for sure
I'll just have a look about the snake
because it is a cobra we have to be very
careful so it's understandable that
people in India are scared of venomous
snakes
1.4 million people in India are bitten
by snakes every year and that's leading
to 45 000 deaths
I'm not a hundred percent confident
about walking into a room and I know
there's a cobra in there but I don't
know where it is
I'm just gonna stand
um where there's open space
near there in that corner
okay wow
my God
it's a big cobra
I can see him
it is dangerous to approach okay I'm
gonna move out of the way then
a snake doesn't want to bite you it
takes a lot of energy for them to be
able to produce that Venom and they want
to save it for their prey it's only
going to bite if it doesn't think it has
any other option
he is very common lying down once I move
this the stick he is going to run
anywhere so I may have to quickly handle
him
there is no other option if the snake
moves out from that corner no one run
everyone just stay very still a snake is
not going to strike you if you're not
moving
all right but you get in there yeah
yeah so get them to move this let us see
what is he going to do
it's a good big cobra
you can see him so what we are going to
do is we are not going to make him very
much
once the Cobra is scared he will be
definitely taking his hook who doubt
like that again same like now his foot
is out yeah now he's he's nervous so we
have to be very careful
so this is the way I handle the cobras
or any snake it is very good to handle
them freely and not giving them much
tension for being what we want to do
when I'm handling a cobra I'm not scared
but I know the consequences what will
happen to me or you or anybody Cobra
Venom is neurotoxic
it prevents you from breathing and it
can do that very quickly in fact the
Venom can start working within about 15
minutes
really the only thing that can help you
out at that point is uh is Anti-Venom
and that's more than an hour away
it is easy to make him go like this he's
doing what's very natural to him exactly
because it is very dark
so we keep the stick here we tie in here
so now he's little nervous
is really worried now yeah he's quite
agitated that surprises me I didn't
expect him to dislike the bag so much we
have to be careful while tying because
we don't want him to come back he did
take a look at your toe there I noticed
yes yes and then we can just bag him in
slowly and uh container now you can
close it oh look there's your little
Noggin yeah
make sure that's definitely not going to
come undone
I don't feel good about the snake
makes me kind of tense
with the emergency over hessy catches up
with the teacher who first discovered
the cobra
this snake has venom it's dangerous
it came like this yes really oh
that's scary I'm happy you are first
times oh it's your first time yes
animal lover I love it yeah thank you so
much okay she saw the snake she was
quite nervous her heart was pounding she
called the police and then she went back
and took a bunch of photos
bye guys bye thank you that's probably
what I would have done also to be honest
yeah that was super cool
nice cool car yes happy snake cobras are
nocturnal Snake species so we're going
to release this guy in the evening when
it's nice and cool
[Music]
[Applause]
at the elephant Sanctuary the team has
started treating the injuries of its
most recent rescue kalpana what is this
but the Vets also need to heal her
psychological wounds
we are about to introduce kalpana to
potentially
a friend you cannot have a good life as
a female elephant without elephant
friends
like kalpana Holly was a begging
elephant
Decades of abuse has led to Chronic
arthritis and blindness
but Compassionate Care from the team is
given Holly a new lease on life since
one of the gentlest elephant that we
have she's one of the sweetest elephants
in wildlife
[Music]
team doubts that 40-year-old kalpana has
ever met another elephant let alone made
friends with one
[Music]
like 50 times two elephants just hit it
off right off the bat and sometimes they
hate each other immediately so it could
really go either way
[Music]
there's Holly and she seems interested
now
kalpana seems quite eager
I really hope these girls like each
other because I think they could be
really good for each other
oh
this is exciting oh my goodness
that's an exciting greeting
[Music]
listen to that rumbling yeah yeah
they're talking
I don't see any aggression between them
which is great in reliving holy seems to
be checking and smelling kalpana
that's a comforting gesture you know
when they put the trunk in other
elephant's mouth
that's kind of a greeting and comforting
you know to say something like it's okay
you know
they're using all sorts of different
sounds and signals to communicate with
each other we know that elephants have a
vast repertoire of communication
abilities and we don't understand their
language per se but they understand each
other there's something really special
going on
couple is doing it yeah yeah oh my God
she's just being a good friend
they really like each other
this is exactly
what we wanted which is great and I hope
holy kind of shows it around and takes
it around the enclosure
oh it's a dust bath time
[Music]
it's always the test part time
okay let's leave them alone now they
look happy with each other thank you
Holly
[Music]
it's really important as a vet to be
able to step back from the medicine and
and just appreciate these animals for
who they are
this was a really special moment I've
never seen anything like that before
that was amazing
with dusk approaching Beijing head out
to a local bird sanctuary to release the
classroom cobra
be careful sure no worries
so we can release somewhere here it is a
good place inside the jungle we do have
like a bit of a clearing here which is a
good place to release a snake because
you can actually see him move away from
you they camouflage incredibly well
baiju is really moving now he wants out
exactly look at him yeah
buys you around cobras is like a teenage
boy in love he just thinks they're like
the most wonderful beautiful cute things
should I back up a little a little bit
better that's not exactly how I feel but
he does have a lifetime of experience
handling cobras so I'm just gonna hang
out several steps behind him and follow
his lead
[Music]
as soon as he finds that way out he's
going to be gone
so you can see it now now it's going to
go exciting yes
stop he's gone
off like a shot
super fast
look at him look at him
he's rearing up he's got his hood out
that is a gorgeous snake I mean just
look at him I mean he just looks like
this is where he belongs
yes
it's a very good habitat you can see the
trees exactly his color
it's like a camouflage
glad we released him same day
for me rescue is always completed when
it is released yeah for sure
mission accomplished
this is a really pretty area and he can
just live a natural life
[Music]
as the sun sets on the sanctuary come on
Karthik and his Wildlife SOS team are
planning a surprise for kalpina and her
new best friend Holly she's coming out
of
work yes
it's exciting she's hesitant
she's looking back to check if Holly is
following her or not she's so scared of
leaving Holly behind
so the incredible this bond that they've
created
I think humans have a lot to learn from
these elephants
Karthik is taking them down to the river
come on for what could be the first time
in their lives
what do you think of that
come on
slowly slowly don't slip don't slip go
gently gentle gentle
Holly is already having a great time as
you can see she's throwing water all
over herself
it's great she is finally in the river
I think it's incredible that these two
elephants who never had a hope
now have a proper life and it's really
quite an emotional moment for us
I think if elephants like kalpana who
came in such a bad State can actually
have an opportunity a second chance I
think there is hope for all elephants in
India
thank you
[Music]